[Applause]
hello greetings salutations uh welcome
to this next episode of down the middle
this is the last we're going to be
filming here in our austin series but we
will come back in six months and film
again
once again here because i just i can't
get enough of the view of my alma mater
which i think i've said a few times now
but i have great pleasure of being in
the company this morning of tim barrett
he's the cio the chief investment
officer of texas tech
university's
endowment and yet we're not filming in
lubbock welcome thank you thank you why
are we not filming in lubbock well we
could have filmed islamic uh but the
investment office uh was moved here
about the time i joined texas tech um
and they moved it here for a reason um
austin is flourishing with with money
so you think utemko trs ers
the number of managers that flow through
here
is astounding
so part of the idea was just to be in
the flow
with other institutional investors and
asset managers well that makes sense
plus you get to live in austin plus you
get to live in awesome there's a little
bit of lows no no offense not in lubbock
but
okay i'm not a big tech fan either
anyways that's different
we don't know i mean i'm just mean
football okay all right and and i can't
i have no bragging rights about football
right now at all um
so i i just
bought a second little itty bitty teeny
weeny cottage in culver indiana
uh we we call it the barbie house it's
so small but
my my third and fourth
child are about to go to culver in their
third generation and so
you grew up in some cold country i did
yes it's cold up there yeah i grew up in
you know central illinois so uh kind of
in the middle of the state near near
springfield
i grew up kind of in a farming community
really a very small town our whole town
at
at the peak five thousand people
major metropolis
and uh both sides of grandparents were
farmers my dad owned an irrigation
company so i kind of grew up
working in fields
well that'll give you labor that one's
still a midwest work ethic
i think it did that and it also makes
you really want to go to college
oh yeah
yeah you should do that work for a while
and you're like yeah yeah i think we can
do better my oldest is uh
was you know i suggested purdue and he
said i'm out of here right i'm so out of
here i'm not going to college in the
cold so i see where you're coming from
uh but growing up you were um you were a
basketball player growing up even though
even though you preferred football i was
a better football player so i rode the
bench a lot in basketball but
the probably the funniest story i got on
the basketball side was when the coach
would put me in and this will give you a
perfect example of my skill set in
basketball
he's like listen tim rebound pass the
ball play good defense that's what
you're good at whatever you do do not
shoot it
don't shoot the ball
so my job was kind of more the enforcer
guy in there and make sure the guys that
actually had skill and could shoot and
make it
had the ball
and i i remember this one time i i
couldn't help myself i was wide open on
the baseline and i was going to launch
it
and man did i launch it that thing was
an air ball probably a foot over the rim
within two seconds it was timeout i was
riding the pine again
because i didn't learn my lesson that
day
and you were the ducks which is a very
intimidating mascot super intimidating
yeah we're the mad ducks we told
ourselves i mean
duck or longhorns
duck they're gonna quack you to death
yeah it was pretty funny
what
what so so you left for college where'd
you go i went to university of montana
my older brother was living in montana
and i loved it out there so i went there
so you stayed in the cold i did stay in
the cold and then
after i finished that run
i went to warmth so then i went to san
diego uh state for graduate school okay
so i decided you know what i've had
enough of the mountains in the freezing
i'm gonna go to the beach
yeah
and how was that
fabulous after a few years in montana
the the san diego lifestyle is pretty
good
so yeah i loved it and that's actually
where i first kind of fell in love with
investing
um i didn't really know what i wanted to
do out of undergrad but when i got to
graduate school i was on a in an
investment club where we managed a
portfolio yeah and professors kind of
oversee it and kind of guide you
ut has the same kind of yeah so me and
somebody as we were running it and uh we
every weekend we'd work on neuro nets
and stuff like that on the weekend
trying to develop better stock picking
skills yeah and uh just kind of fell in
love with the whole process in the
markets
so
walk us through how you got from san
diego to
texas tech
that's that's a little longer story but
um that's okay the
san diego when i was doing that i uh
started looking for work in the industry
it was very difficult to walk right into
a money manager
one of the friends i went to with in
grad school ended up getting a job at
san bernadino county retirement
association
which is it's kind of east of los
angeles
um kind of in between los angeles and
palm springs on the 10th
so it was it was not a
super large
pension fund like los angeles
or calpers or anything but i think at
the time it was like three billion
dollars
um which at the time was substantial
we're talking 96
uh right now
so he kept he kept reaching you started
in 96 yeah and i started okay we both
got our mbas in 96. yeah okay cool and
then i i he kept calling me saying you
got to come here look at this pension
system
and i i wasn't real sure because i kind
of really wanted to be on the asset
management side yeah but i wouldn't have
much luck so eventually i decided to go
work there and i
kind of came in as a project manager
doing some tech stuff and then also the
other half time working on investments
and within three years i was the cio
there
because he moved on and
they did a national search and i ended
up winning it
so i stayed there for almost 15 years
wow
after i was cio i i think three years
later i became the executive director
and cio
which by the way is a huge win
because usually you got to ask the ceo
of you about the investment strategy
talk to them then you go to the board so
you kind of got to get an internal
blessing right
well once you become the ceo and cio you
ask yourself
whether you want to take it so now that
now that now the portfolio strategy
changes based on what you think it
should change you just have to ask
yourself and then go to the board and
convince them
so it was a big win you were in asset
management
i was at that stage right and now i
could really decide portfolio structure
and as long as i could sell it to the
board i could i could implement it yeah
that's so cool
uh and something called you
at some point texas beckoned all right
there there was an interim step there um
so after almost 15 years there i decided
to go to the corporate side
so i went to kodak and went back to the
cold as you might say
so think of rochester new york kodak
okay for you younger viewers google
kodak with a k yeah okay google it
there's a paul simon song for you called
kodachrome
but um
i went there um
mainly for the experience because it was
16 billion dollar
system
they really had no staff
they ran portable alpha which we can
talk about later but sure but i also ran
that as san bernardino which made me a
good fit there
um but they had 77 plans around the
world
and wow the idea that i could run
european plans asian plants everything
and have my hands globally
and get experience with different boards
around the world
was really intriguing to me that's so
cool
and so then you went and saw the world
so i went saw the world and realized i'm
never home
um which was hard with little kids and i
did that for about three years it
through the kodak bankruptcy wow which
is a completely new story about what we
did in europe during the bankruptcy
um
there is no pbgc there's no pension
benefit guarantee corporation in europe
there isn't and we actually i think
we're the only people in history to
during bankruptcy sell off
companies
to the pension system and have the
pension system there forgive any
liabilities to the mothership of the
united states and then reattach to those
companies we saw sold them
and we got regulator approval for all of
that and we did all of that within about
a two-year span
and it's like a massive unwind that you
it's a massive unwind and that released
all the liabilities of that pension
system back to kodak and less
which could subsequently be
written off could be written off correct
so that was that was a massive
undertaking a lot of work it's also
fascinating you get to work with a lot
of really smart uh regulators as well as
advisors in europe to get that done
um it reminds me of lehman when it went
down i mean there were people who who
had who made entire careers
out of unwinding lehman oh absolutely
absolutely
um so after that that was
about three years and then
that's when texas tech came calling
so
one of my friends mentioned to me that
they were looking for a cio and
uh you know honestly my first just was
i'm not going to lubbock
well my first question was where's texas
tech located
then the second one was i'm not going i
don't think i can go to lubbock i don't
think my wife would would let me go
there wait remind me of what the mantra
is with the football games oh thumbs up
get your guns out guns up get your guns
out right okay i supposed to hook them
all right
so anyway um
i ended up interviewing and taking that
job and they they at the time had
already decided
that they're either going to relocate to
dallas or austin sure um and of course i
i think i had some influence on that and
they said i think austin's great spot
yeah
and uh you know the rest is history
we've been here
i've been here almost eight years now um
as cio of texas tech and it's been a
great run
so um
talk about um
talk about how pensions differ
i mean
a lot of pensions are obviously at
their most funded
public pensions defined benefits are at
their most
liquid funded stage that they've been at
in
like a generation
just by virtue of the fact that they're
exposed to the public stock market
alone
but yeah but talk about how pensions
differ in terms of their governance in
terms of asset allocation
who has influence because when you think
about a
a teacher's retirement system in any
state for example
you're going to have like a
a great person who's a third grade
teacher on your board right
right and
they might not be
they might not be able to sit down and
have a full discussion with you about
alpha and beta and gamma
i can almost guarantee you can't have
that discussion but um there's massive
differences uh in my opinion as you as
you work through pension to corporate to
kind of endowment foundation
um
from a governance standpoint and i think
people put them all together they do
when i can i can understand the desire
to want to put them together because in
the end
it yes they're different from a
governance standpoint they're different
from a talent standpoint a pay
standpoint which i get into
but in the end they're all trying to do
the same thing and that's why people
lump them together because if if you're
not in the business itself then they all
look the same right they're all trying
to get eight to ten percent return
and they're trying to do that as
consistent as possible yeah but they're
going about it completely different
yeah
so i mean when you look at
when you look at allocations to
alternatives and some of the most
underfunded pensions
you'll find that their allocation
alternatives is substantially larger
yeah than that of more conservatively
run
pensions that are more funded yeah i i
think that's absolutely true
so if you look at like san bernardino i
think it's a perfect example and there's
20 systems in cal in california that run
under what's called the 1937 act
and they're all county retirement
systems including los angeles county
which is the largest system of all of
them
and they're very similar to to all
public systems in that they get elected
members and appointed members
so the board of supervisors in this case
would appoint like half the members
the other half are elected by the
membership itself like whether that is
the sheriff's association the
firefighters or the general employees
gotcha
none of those elected people have any
skill set whatsoever in investments like
zero but it's a half it's it's a half
and half
even the appointed ones when you're
talking about being from these certain
counties like if you're in los angeles
you might be able to find investment
people
when you're out in san bernardino
you might get an accountant on there you
might get a business owner on there
they're not investment professionals by
any stretch of imagination so it's what
you end up with is a group of really
novice people
who are trying to guide the ship
and they're trying to guide in really
unfamiliar territory right which is why
they can be guided
that's why they can be guided so the
really critical point is having a strong
leader and a strong investment person at
the helm to do that
i think the second piece you see at
public funds is just widespread use of
consultants
right since they don't really understand
what they do they want that second
opinion from the consultant right which
is a good decision
but it's only a good decision if you
have any somebody strong at the helm
that's actually making the decisions and
the consultants kind of verifying that
yeah this is good direction right i
think once you get to the other side of
the equation where you let consultants
drive the whole portfolio i think it
gets messy really quick so i'll tell you
a funny story um
in 2004 i think i was at an omaha i got
to go meet warren buffett but i really
spent time with charlie munger and
he made this comment
that
one day when central bankers were less
influential
in the markets the the entire
pension consulting
industry would go the way the dodo bird
it would just disappear
and i i'm looking at him and he's 80
something at the time and i was like
that's really deep and he's like yeah
the whole efficient frontier
will go away and i was actually speaking
with somebody who studied under fama
under gene fama
and gene thomas changed his mind on the
on his own efficient frontier right
right and he's a nobel prize winner but
he's like no don't work anymore it
doesn't work
it's fascinating yeah but the consultant
the consultant industry is based on that
it is based on that but i think you know
if you really dig down to the heart and
essence of it and think about why
why does the board want that
it honestly goes back to cya right they
want somebody to lean on they want money
to say hey
i know we lost 100 billion dollars in
the sell-off
but the consultant thought this was the
most prudent asset allocation and we're
sticking to our guns and that's the
mantra right and people in life
so i think that that paints a good
picture of of the public funds and
there's always exceptions right there's
you know texas teachers is a great
exception i think if you look at them
that's an extremely well-run public fund
yes um so they run the gamut where
you'll find really well-run ones and
poor ones just like anything
then switch to corporate
corporate to me and grant it you know
i've only worked for one corporate so
i'm generalizing here but sure
the
board at kodak the way it was made up
for the investment committee was the
treasurer himself
who i worked right next door to and
reported to
and then the cfo was on the board head
of hr etc
so there was a handful they were all
working people in the corporation with
the corporation's best interest at mind
but they were busy all day so they
didn't have all day to sit around pick
through your portfolio and ask you what
you were doing nor do they want to right
in there
it is you deliver against the liability
curve
or you get fired
and it's it's very straightforward
pretty simple so i mean that was
literally the thing the treasurer said
to me day one like if you lose money
against this liability curve we're gonna
fire you
and i looked at the portfolio and i'm
like
i go you know we're gonna make a lot of
changes really fast
right because they were not hedging
their liabilities all the way right so i
was taking a huge liability mismatch
that's like the very first thing we're
going to do because you're really well
funded
is we're tightening up the liability
curve dramatically and we're going to
start taking some beta off the table and
be a more absolute return against that
veteran
um
you can say that that was really smart
way to run a portfolio it's really about
self preservation here
[Laughter]
i was uh i definitely need to make those
changes make it work but i think the
biggest difference is the governance
right so when you roll through to that
group
i would tell them what i was doing with
the portfolio and i would take my
manager selections or my ass allocation
changes to them
and you know they would read through the
memo real quick and it was quick those
meetings were like an hour and a half
long they might have six major changes
and they'd go through them and they'd
say the treasurer's job was to really
look at it they kind of glance over him
and say did you go through all this bill
and they'll go yeah it looks good to me
they'd go oh yeah it looks good go yeah
cause all bill all bill knew was that he
was going to fire you a few right it was
pretty silly
yeah right
um but you could move way quicker and
you also don't have the time when you
have 77 plans globally
to sit around and discuss it you have to
grant authority to your investment team
and let them do their job so i'm
i'm curious because we've seen so many
um pensions disappear
in
corporate pensions right disappear in
recent years and they've kind of
sloughed them off to
insurance companies and um
are you allowed to do that in other
countries
uh not as easily it depends on each
country is different okay um but i'll
pick europe because that's the easiest
one everybody knows about
really hard to do in europe
if you you go try to shut down a pension
plan in france which by the way we tried
um the amount of checks you gotta write
almost makes it not worth trying to shut
down
because you've got to pay for the
employees if you're gonna especially if
you're laying them off you've got to pay
for them for a long time then you've got
to pay off that liability
you're almost better just trying to keep
the company going and finding the buyer
for the company
is a better exit strategy wow
it's very very difficult because if you
think about the the companies that have
that still have divine benefit plans and
i mean you can practically name them at
this point yeah but they're
international operations like ford or
general motors or caterpillar or
general steel or
i think it puts them at a competitive
disadvantage if you think about the new
and upcoming companies
um because the new and upcoming
companies won't give those benefits you
know they know the rules now so they're
always going to put 401ks or the
equivalent of a european 401k
into place to not have that liability or
yeah of course i mean they've learned
um
so let's let let's uh and and just one
last thing on the uh when you think
about the corporate site we kind of
talked about that and then endowment
side right i think
the biggest difference in endowment
foundations even more so than corporate
and more definitely more so you're
getting endowments and foundations
together i kind of locking them together
um it is really skill set
so when you look at the boards that
typically the board members that sit on
an endowment or foundation
a lot of times they're guys that worked
at a hedge fund
um or they're a private equity guy or a
real estate guy they're guys in the
business that are on those boards
now depending where your foundation or
endowment is you may not have 100 of
that
but you're going to have a number of
people on that board to understand your
language understand what you're doing
understand market cycles
and honestly
in many ways makes it easier for the cio
to get things done
well sure they're they they literally
speak your same language and it changes
your support metric for when things go
bad so like markets always ebb and flow
and it's
you're going to have tough years as a
cio no matter what if you have a board
of professionals that actually
understand that as well and work in the
industry
they understand that when it goes down
it's likely time to step on the gas not
get scared right um and if you have the
other board the public fund when things
go down they retrench and lock
everything down yeah so when you're
supposed to step on the gas they never
do and that's why so many of them have
never come back that's right that's
right
fascinating fascinating fascinating um
so how
how should
ideally
in your mind how should
any defined benefit plan be allocated in
this world that we live in today by the
way
the thought crossed my mind that jay
powell could be on uh
he could sit on a foundation board if in
four years if you know if he leaves the
fed he could theoretically that would be
a great job for him yeah something tells
me that he won't but that it would be a
great job
um how to allocate in this environment
is a great question
um i would say
you know now
it's time to curb your enthusiasm i
think it's the best way i would say it
for everybody
um
well don't tell that to uh don't don't
tell that to a dogecoin owner oh right
yeah
exactly whoever just bought the nft for
450 000 for snoop dogg's virtual party
house that is definitely going to be
worth like 5 million later
okay
now
yeah i don't really understand that part
of the market um i've i've heard about
some of those things i heard another one
where a guy bought
an architectural drawing of a house on
mars of course all made up
and paid millions of dollars for it in
the nft i'm like what are you gonna do
with that
i mean it's the ultimate ultimate sucker
trade right like you buy that and you're
hoping the ultimate sucker is there to
buy it from you later but it's also
emblematic of
from the biggest perspective all the way
out to mars it's also emblematic of how
much liquidity is sloshing around in the
system
and the last time we had this much
liquidity sloshing around in systems
yeah i think it goes right back to your
question on how to allocate now right so
if you think about where are valuations
right now right
through the roof right especially if you
look at u.s stocks even more so than
your appearance
you look at credit spreads they're tight
you couldn't get much tighter
um and that's interesting is negative
yielding and i'm like trying to explain
that to a lay person yes for a
high-yield bond has got a an inflation
adjusted negative yielding they're like
what right
it makes you say yeah golden cash looks
pretty good right now when you think
about that way
but the problem is is that pension funds
endowments all of us
you can't do that right you have to stay
invested
so now the question is how do you adjust
your allocation well
if you have an equity allocation that's
60 like a lot of people
you've got to push it down to the lower
end of the range
right you got to build your cash
position or your negative convexity
trades right your convex trade so
we have a couple managers that are high
convex fixed income long short guys
uh and we're building much bigger
positions than we're getting at get ray
another manager in that space we already
have one and we're going to severely
overweight those guys pushing more
capital into them
so you're increasing you're increasing
your hedge i'm increasing my my wrist
offset yes my head i wouldn't call it
pure hedge because you know they
generally in a normal market will make
you five to seven kind of percent return
which is nothing special but it's okay
um the fact that it's positive is a home
run yeah and then
you know like one of them one of our
managers
in q1 was up 44
so that convexity pays off when there's
a major dislocation right
so i think you need to find some of that
you need to get some trend offset into
your portfolio this year what's that q1
of 2021 of 20 of 20. okay okay that
makes more sense you want to so what the
pandemic hit one pandemic
uh certain i mean people for people have
clearly forgotten very quickly that we
had multiple circuit circuit breakers go
on a daily basis like throughout the
trading grade you were you were hitting
these circuit breakers that it was just
yeah if you're in the middle if you were
in the in the business you were nauseous
uh that entire day watching it happen
yeah um it was the fastest in history in
my opinion you go back to oh eight and
you had time to adjust
there really wasn't any time to adjust
unless you're trading derivatives you
you had no time to do it well no it
didn't trade derivatives was hard it
actually was the fastest in history
prior to that it was 1933 correct
so
2020 was the fastest 33 i don't recall
um
but i've seen it on paper well yes and
actually 34 was
not pretty right at all
in the markets it's just there was there
was a
the market came way back
in 34 and then it just went into a
long-term slump yeah and i think you're
seeing a little bit of that same kind of
formation now right so you think about
q1 everything tanked
now we're rallying off of just pumped up
liquidity
fed helping the markets like there's no
tomorrow
paying money directly to consumers and
they're spending
all of this is just pushing asset prices
right you go out to bet on an asset now
there's so many people been on every
asset
and you know
that whole idea that i get a proprietary
deal that doesn't even exist oh sure um
and you've got the people you've got the
people with the most money
with the most dry powder who are
bemoaning the fact that there's nothing
to buy and and yet the deals are still
getting
done it's just the multiples are going
through the roof yeah it's it's it makes
an investment job and and trying to run
a portfolio very difficult right now you
know my advice to everybody would be is
get as conservative as you can get
within your policy
i think a perfect example of of what
we're looking at right now is like we're
looking we use uh derivatives to run
portable alpha
which just means that we get our beta
through a derivative like an
aqueous and then we invest in hedge
funds and and hold cash the hedge funds
we turned into swaps
and then now you that way you have way
more cash behind the portable alpha
construct
so the idea is that
you can handle a much much larger
drawdown than what say a traditional
portable outfit structure would allow
in our case we can handle about a 50
drawdown wow with a 0.5 correlation
between the hedge funds and the beta
which by always unheard of like these
these large multi-strat hedge funds
rarely if ever go to a 0.5 correlation
wow
they usually run at closer about point
two to three
um so so presumably there aren't very
many of these amazing hedge funds out
there there's not
uh we typically stick with huge
multi-strats for the portable alpha
construct as you know i would say that
there's
globally that i think are
you know best of breed and you used to
be able to be a very focused hedge fund
but
i mean people forget the idea of
correlation they absolutely do they
forget you know we're sitting here in
artemis capitals offices i mean
christopher cole was the first person to
show me that over the past hundred years
which he looks at often
that real estate is a very pro cyclical
asset class
absolutely
yeah so it's private equity by the way
everybody oh gosh everybody thinks
that's a diverse fire it's not a diverse
fire no
um it is cyclical just like equities
it's actually it's more cyclical than
equities because there's no exit
absolutely at all and they're a liquid
yeah
and we're like everybody else we have
private equity as well and it's done
extremely well this last year
but i would say still you got to go back
to fundamentals now and the fundamentals
don't look good
the technicals don't even look good
right now so like if you just look
underneath the market about how the
market's moving right right a handful of
stocks are driving it and now you're
starting to see a lot of interim
volatility underneath the surface where
you're seeing really good companies down
20 30 percent and you know that'll last
a little while and then liquidity comes
back and people buy those right back up
yeah
um
so that interim volatility i think is a
sign a warning sign for people to think
about that the markets are gonna keep
getting more volatile as we go forward
here
so
outside of
clearly being protected by some of the
best managers
in the world and and how they operate
which is a handful which means that
there aren't
that many people who can gain access
that many investors who can gain access
right and be hedged that's why as
individuals right now you know there's
there's no shame in cash and people
don't emotion i mean i'm i'm i've got a
hug of a relationship with my municipal
bond portfolio because i think that any
legislation that's eventually passed is
going to benefit states municipalities
absolutely agree so it's a great place
to park your money when you don't like
the equity market yeah
um but uh
but talk speak to um
kind of
speak to private equity and then speak
to passive investing because again if
you look at
if you look at the poster child if you
look at the city of chicago
their allocation to alternatives is i
want to say 39 or 40 percent
and they're underfunded
i think by about 60
this is but again this is probably the
worst
there's a competition between the state
of illinois and the city of chicago to
get to the worst funded pensions in the
country kentucky's up there somewhere is
that due to performance or funding
issues because i know in illinois they
have issues of not funding their
pensions oh that will that's the fastest
way to ruin a pension plan is not send
your money in um
but i will talk about private equity a
little bit um
private equity for us so if you think
about our portfolio
we run roughly a 60 40 portfolio
so roughly 60 in equities 40 percent is
public equity
20 we're going to call broadly private
equity okay when i say broadly private
equity there's lots of things that are
private
that are equity oriented right
so
real estate for instance it's private
equity oil and gas stuff that's private
equity in our view yeah um if it's
equity-centric and it's private it's in
that portfolio right
infrastructure i mean there's so many
different
categories that are within
private debt i mean there's so many
so if you think about like what
what would i do in private equity if i
had fresh money right now
you probably should really be thinking
about infrastructure
farmland all of this kind of stuff why
because it does well in inflationary
environments
two it sure appears the government wants
to support infrastructure so you got
wind of your back there yep and three
rates are still cheap
so most of that stuff has leverage
related to it
so it should do pretty well in this
environment
where do you maybe struggle going
like adding more large eye out might be
you know something you might want to tap
down just a little bit
and then
raising record level sizes of funds
the fundraising just continues automated
and it's the public
pensions that are feeding this beast
they're definitely feeding the beast and
they do it for multiple reasons one if
you if you go back over the last let's
call it three decades
right and
look at the alpha generated where use
the term alpha loosely in other words
did it outperform your broad equity
benchmark right right
you go back
three decades ago
private equity crushed it
it wasn't even close compared to the
public markets yeah
no and then that that was i mean i was
i've said this on many interviews i was
i was at donaldson lufkin and generate
dlj
when private equity wasn't even a thing
i mean we had this merchant bank and the
returns you know leon black was walking
around and tony james and schwartzman
was a deal
but their returns
were truly diversifiers they were they
were off
the charts
yeah it was it was a beautiful time to
be in private equity if you were there
yeah
so then then you go the next decade and
you can literally see the charts on this
alpha just dropping right so let's say
it was 15 ahead of the market 30 years
ago
20 years ago it dropped us out
you know what it is today
uh i don't know that it's even positive
it's positive still
but it's real tight is it positive net
of fees
it's yeah it's still positive net of
fees but it's like 200 300 basis points
so now your question is i'm locking up
my money
for 10 years i'm paying somebody a lot
of money to run it this way yeah
i could argue on certain private equity
strategies by out being one of them
that i could grab
a russell 2 and run it at a 1.4
leverage
ratio
maybe running at 1.5 a little higher and
then throw a few hedges on the side and
recreate the same return on private
equity but be liquid but be liquid
is that because you have to ask yourself
is
two or three percentage points
worth the
i mean is that does that pay the
liquidity the illiquidity premium i
don't think it does and in my view you
got to get to about 500
uh in your portfolio if you're not
delivering 500 over the
broad equity markets
i question whether you're you're either
one not doing a good job or two
it's not there anymore you should be
changing strategies
but they can't they can't go to cash
because they keep raising cash that's
true and then the other piece of it i
would say is you know we've talked about
buy out and you know farmland a little
bit and infrastructure
the other piece is growth and venture
capital
and if you go to like the big pension
funds we were talking about earlier they
really don't have access to that why
because those strategies are niche and
they don't take a lot of money and
somebody like texas teachers can't write
a check for 400 million into a venture
capital manager they just don't take
that much money right so the people that
play in there are really endowments
foundations family offices right sure
venture capital has been the hottest
thing
since sliced bread the past two years i
mean look around you it's amazing right
most of our venture capital is up 100 to
300 in the last 12 months gosh right and
we had
exits of some of our private equity
holdings
that are 20 and 30 times money
and i you know i might or might not have
tweeted out about uh jay powell
modifying the main street lending
program to put under the umbrella
portfolio companies of private equity
firms right right i might or might not
have tweeted out about that in
something of a fit of rage
yeah i don't know that that's a good
idea um
the interesting thing i think about the
space and and this goes to the whole
market and this shows how much liquidity
is out there
and it shows how overdone the market is
is all of these private guys typically
raise money on a three-year cycle
like venture capital and stuff with
private bio guys
they're putting money to work so fast
that they're coming back to market in a
year year and a half
and then
the thing with venture capital is you
can't just get in
right it's hard to get into top tier
venture capital guys
and if you say you're out
you're a persona non-protest you're not
coming in next month yeah or if you
shrink your allocation that's your
permanent that's where you're gonna be
they're gonna bring a new client
so
you find yourself stuck in this weird
juxtaposition where you're like i know i
should not be really upping more money
into venture capital yeah
but they're coming out with a second
fund and if we're not supportive of the
firm we're not going to be with the firm
what do you want to do
i mean that's well that's a dilemma it
is a dilemma you know for us so far
we're continuing to do it i think the
advantage we have is
we started our venture capital program
five years ago
so it's still new
um
so if we if we overweight a little bit
we're okay
somebody that has a program
you know like a yale
or any other big boy that's been around
for
decades and been in the in the venture
capital business or rather
i would think that they would have even
a bigger problem
just because everybody's asking for the
same thing and are they really going to
come back
um and then you get into a different
liquidity problem because venture
capital won't always be hot
it's gone decades where it's anemic and
you're not really getting paid to be in
it well i mean
one of my favorite statistics was this
is pre-pandemic
was that as levered up as large
companies were
small and medium enterprises were
levered up even by a multiple of two
times what
you know we're all worried about the
corporate bond market blowing up and jay
powell comes out and rescues and bails
out the corporate bond market and gets
you know gets married to the treasury to
do it but that was not the most levered
up little slice of corporate america i
agree i agree
so i you know i think the private equity
business now is like the public equity
business it's it's
one it's overdone it's super competitive
so you're seeing
the amount of money you make on it go
down and down
um and by the way this is true in hedge
funds too so it's true across the board
because what we call is just declining
alpha everywhere
so this really gets back to you your
question about you know
when you mentioned chicago and how much
alternatives they had
you know if the alpha is declining in
private assets
if alpha is declining in your hedge fund
strategies
i mean the original hedge funds were to
beat the equity market that was that's
what that's why they're that's why
they're making hedge funds people forget
that they were designed to head but
they're not using that anymore
like hardly anybody hires a hedge fund
to beat the equity market
they have equity allocation it's over
here or it's in the private equity or
public efforts it's not a hedge fund
they're they're using hedge fund as
diversification strategies why because
the alpha's gone down so low
that it can't be called anything but
that it is now a bond replacement
diversification strategy
right
um
and there is a place for that i believe
in the portfolio
just because of what's happened to the
yield curve
if you look at where yields are now like
does it pay to own the bar cap i'm going
to tell you absolutely not
right
that's a big part of pension funds yeah
so you need to find a liquid or at least
pseudo liquid replacement hedge funds
fill a great role there um
or you're not getting alpha that you
would in equities but you're getting
enough to beat the bond market which by
the way is negative so it's not not i
hurdle
so that takes me back to your other
question about passive right so when we
think about
we think about private equity you know
you got to be with the best of the best
in my opinion to get that liquidity
premium
when you go up to the public equity
markets
everybody seems to be passive that trend
has been going on for a decade i think
you you talked on some of your pieces
about it yes i mean but again if this is
i keep telling people you know in 2006
the law changed requiring human resource
managers
to you know
it was the opt-in law that was first so
new employees have to be opted into the
401k if within 30 days of being opted in
they have not designated how they want
to
uh to allocate their 401k
money what funds they want to put it in
of the limited choices they have then
the hr manager by the law of the united
states is required to put them in into a
target date fund yeah that happened in
2006. i think it's a safe harbor choice
right i think is what they called it
kodak uh did the same thing right so
they had all target date funds and
every time somebody joined boom you're
in it right yeah
and i don't think most people ever look
at it again to be honest um because
supposedly it's set up for you
um
you're right that drives passive
investing right
it i mean it drives it to an increasing
degree as
because of the demographics because the
average american right now is 39 years
old
so that alone tells you kind of where
the target date of the country is
if you will it's kind of 39 61.
so every every two weeks paychecks come
out go in and drive those drive those
markets
then the second side of that i would say
over the last
well since since i've been in the
business of 96
like i remember in 96 when i got to the
portfolio
we had passive but the majority of our
equity portfolio was active
right the majority of them and that was
every pension fund was very similar
fast forward to the day you got smp
putting out the persistence report which
i'm sure everybody's seeing which shows
how many active managers have beaten the
index over one year periods over three
year periods over five year periods over
ten year periods
and if you pull that report and just
about anybody can get it yeah you see
that active managers
dramatically underperform
over time right well part of the reason
is what you mentioned right more and
more flow
from the passive side
through these target date funds and
through pension funds pushing more money
to pass it
pushes the exact same stocks up
so if you're in our management there are
five or six of them right now absolutely
stocks
in total that are driving driving the
market that are driving the market
people
i mean people are like yeah this is just
like the nifty 50s and i'm like there's
no 50. right 50 was diversified exactly
50 was like enormous there's no there's
no 50 there's a handful yeah
absolutely agree
and i think that's gonna keep going on
for a while right because i don't see
target date fund solutions changing that
that's a mechanism that's in place
that's a lot and hard to change right
then so then you got to switch to you
know the big institutional buyers
are they going to change their views
that's a that's like turning the titanic
you know you'll have a few mavericks
change their view some guys are really
thinking outside the box they'll change
their view but the vast majority will
not which means that's going to keep
going as those funds grow yeah so i
don't i don't see i mean that's right
you know that's why you you could
potentially see you know
what you've just described is why people
now say nasdaq is the risk-free asset
right which makes your head hurt it
absolutely does
yeah and it's it's definitely not the
risk-free asset i know
um but it's it's because of this
i don't think that people have
necessarily gone and done the modeling
and and and look to see what every
marginal dollar that goes into passive
you know
how much how much bit of a multiplier
that is versus one dollar active yeah
but it's
it's it's huge and it's growing yeah
i would say when you're when you're in a
bull market like we've been in the last
uh 18 months ever since q1 of
20. oh i would argue since 2009 well
it's actually been longer we had the
blip of q120 but
you could go back then and it doesn't
really matter if you're in passive or
active because the indices just have
gone through the roof with all the fed
support
so to me the real question is
when when that changes right and i think
you're already starting seeing claims of
this and i'm sure you've talked about it
right is
when rates start going up and the yield
curve changes you've already seen just
the scare of the rate curve going up
hitting
software companies and tech companies
i've never seen the yield curve compress
so fast in we've both been in the
business 25 years i've never seen the
yield curve compress as fast as it is
i've never seen the short end go up as
quickly as it is in the long end come
down as quickly as it is
so it i think every investor should be
asking themselves what happens when the
10 years at three if we go there rapidly
i i can tell you what's going to happen
the stock market is going to take a hit
like you haven't seen in a long time
then what happens if we just go ahead
and add on liquidity i'll push back i
think the fed's going to tighten into an
inverted yield curve you think so
i think that they're going to be faced
with that choice yeah
because i've never seen
i i've never seen a curve try and race
to an inversion as quickly as it is
i don't think i would disagree with that
because they're going to have to push
front-end rates they're behind the curve
right so
the ultimate dilemma right
sure you're almost but you could get
back to a stagflation argument pretty
rapidly
um stagflation's not good for stocks
and
you're you're going to see trouble there
right now i mean speculation preceded
the the lowest price to earnings ratio
since
that 1920.
in 1981 that that's stagflation made
stocks really you know make stocks cheap
again it would it'll make stocks cheap
again
i i i don't disagree with you i think
you could easily see the front end of
the curve come up stocks sell sell-off
and then the outlook be poor because we
still have fairly persistent inflation
yeah
i mean i mean i think 2022 is going to
be
we were speaking before we were on film
i mean you know just just the gaming of
the what used to be called food stamps
and now it's
you know supplemental
nutrition assistance program i mean the
gaming is a much nicer name now that way
snap sounds
food stamps now but just just it there's
certain idiosyncratic drivers of
inflation
that are going to be hard to pull down
food inflation being one of them because
people are selling their snack cards for
for to get cash for
50 cents on the dollar whatever
we were talking about the ports of los
angeles and long beach and you know
their contract is up on june 30th so
they'll likely
they've gone on strike every single time
their contract has been negotiated since
1990. so the likelihood of history tells
you that they're gonna run strike yeah
so
let's say we start unwinding the mess at
the ports
and then they go on strike
right back you're back with freight
costs that are
so there's there are some
and then i think this is even in the
face of inventories building i think
you're going to have an inventory i
think you can have a stockpiling problem
soon but it won't matter freight's still
through the roof to your margins i mean
i think companies natural reaction to
this probably would be to stock
inventory right as soon as they can get
it oh there's already if they don't
trust the system right right you're
going to overstock inventory which is
what is that a drag on margins again
right
um so we're back to the same thing which
is we have an overvalued stock market
now we have another influence hitting
margins
we're not even talking rates yet but if
the rates move too
and then that third piece to me is like
what are they going to do with the
balance sheet they've been buying assets
pumping liquidity in the market
they're talking about tapering reducing
them out they're buying what happens
when it starts going really quick and
you're really pulling it out
and that's what i mean you know that
does you know
the old jay powell went away the minute
he was renominated and he started
talking tough again like he like he was
when he first became
you know chair in 2017.
it was meet the new jay powell he was
same as the old from 2017 before the pal
pivot right so if he gets i mean you
know it's it's tradition that the fed
not
uh not change policy right before
christmas and yet
here we go here we go
yeah it brings you back to portfolio
positions and how do you think about
solving for that problem
and um
it is a super difficult thing for any
cio right because you've got to stay
invested
so there's only a few levers you can
pull you can put some more hedges on but
right now hedging's crazy expensive
right
you can put we were talking about that
you can put some counter train stuff
onto the portfolio um
and you could put some you know swaps
and and things that that trade
counter to the market in other words
momentum-based strategies that will go
long and short
um that will help you out are you and
you're getting precious metals
you can't own precious metals you're
allowed okay um
any endowment can buy commodity funds
and all that all that kind of thing okay
and that's not a bad place to go is to
park money and commodities i would say
that if you're going to go commodities
you'd want to go long short with a
really confident manager yeah because
right now
commodities are trading in different
directions really careful between you
know somewhere between iron ore and
soybeans you're like whoa you drive a
mack truck through that so yeah and
you know my personal view on oil is it's
going to go through the roof
just based on policy right the policy in
the united states the policy globally is
all to see how many how much lithium we
can mine to build batteries for cars
yeah i mean france shuts down everything
france is sitting on top of one of the
biggest shales on the planet
and all the french banks have made a
pact to not provide financing to anybody
who wants to frack in france yep
and it's here too we're pressing we're
pressing hard against uh our oil and gas
people to not do it i don't know if you
saw recently there was like 16 states
banned together and sent a letter to all
the banks saying hey we're going to
create our own bank if you don't if you
mistreat or treat people poorly they're
in the oil and gas business
there's a lot of pushback coming from
states they're worried about the economy
and jobs
and the banks are worried about esg and
the global environment right
um and it's that clash that's a lot of
tension that's a lot of tension and
whenever you have
a lack of capital in anything right when
the capital runs away
then the opportunities are massive right
um
so i do think that i mean the irony for
me is that electric vehicles require
you know they chew it more
environmentally than internal combustion
engines but nobody nobody wants to talk
about that yeah i've seen some studies
where a guy he went through and did a
really deep analysis saying like what is
the break-even rate if you consider you
know what it costs to mine and what that
does to the environment exactly and how
long do you actually have to drive that
electric car and where's that break-even
point
and it was a ridiculous number it was
like nine years yeah and last time i
checked i don't know anybody in my
neighborhood that keeps a car for nine
years well now you've met somebody you
have yes
well i haven't i have a 19 year old land
cruiser that is awesome well they're
they're built to last forever they are
i think almost everybody i know has uh
you know they just sit around doing the
leases and get a new car every three
years oh i mean i i you see it you see
it everywhere i mean
where i live in dallas it's the number
one mclaren market in the country right
and it's just
and so let's let's shift gears okay um
because i was recently
at highland park village met a
girlfriend for lunch it's kind of
it's it's kind of the
the the toniest area that you could it's
the rodeo drive of dallas nice so it's
got chanel it's got gucci it's got fendi
it's got hermes
it has every high-end store that you
could possibly ever name
and i happened to happen to be there on
a saturday
meeting a girlfriend for lunch
and there were lines everywhere lines
lines long lines
long lines outside of chanel there was a
line outside the rolex store that had no
merchandise in the window
no merchandise because if i was there on
a saturday it had opened on a friday and
it sold out within an hour
that's insane the rolex store
so
um so high-end market looks good the
rich are really rich right
and they you know if you look at it in
the broadest sense the top 10 account
for 22.3 of us consumption
but when you get down to certain
discretionary type of purchases and this
is all bureau of labor statistics data
when you get down to certain
discretionary areas
there are upwards of 40 45
of consumption in these areas the rich
are really rich
so i mean my question to you is and this
is getting to the fundamentals the risks
the risk that you look at
outside of
just through that
that prism of the markets right so
if you're a busboy
in the restaurant where i have lunch
and you see all these lines
you're mad
yeah
i i can't imagine that you're not
yeah i think
i think you're talking a little bit
about kind of what the whole cultural
part of the cultural problem in the
united states and globally is right
um i don't think that's just here
i think we're a great example of
of having a bifurcation problem
um the question is for a developed
country we have the biggest we have the
biggest for a developed country but i'm
i'm not exactly sure how that gets fixed
because that has to get fixed by people
that are also very wealthy and called
congress
right yeah we have to have a functional
congress mostly congressmen are
millionaires yeah um
and so you're asking them to tax
themselves yeah nancy pelosi has got her
own chat room
that's just an investment following of
just her investments but that's really
what has to happen if you want a
redistribution of the wealth
i'd say the other thing is that
the cycle of the markets also really
helps the wealthy
so the boom and boss cycle
one rich people can handle the boom and
bust cycle and two they have enough
capital to deploy when it does bust to
buy up everything yeah and we've been
doing that cycle for quite a long time
and the way that they're running the fed
and the way that we're running the
global economies it's happening more
frequently yes which just means that
wealth compounds faster for the wealthy
and it more frequently wipes out
the underprivileged or or the lower
class people even that's why the middle
class is disappearing by the way oh i
mean what what the fiscal yeah when you
wipe them out once what the fiscal
you know
what the cares act started with the care
attack did to the to the to the united
states small business owner is just
tragic i mean we're like big boxes and
oligopolies and
chain restaurants
it's i mean it's it's like it's like
watching the soul of the country gets
sucked away it's just
but there's something economic about
inequality as well it presents a
fundamental risk to the economy
i think it does because eventually
people quit working and i think we're
seeing that now right
people start dropping out
of the economy because they're not
rewarded for being in it right
um
you know that's that's a concept and a
problem in this country that i don't
know that i have a solution for
personally i wish i did well it started
it starts with education which is that
that takes you back to a dysfunctional
congress
the education but i mean we're at a
point now
and i i i work for an educational
institution so i probably should be
careful what i say but we're at a point
now where
we're sending an awful lot of kids to
school with an awful lot of debt
they're coming out with a lot of debt
and we're saying go get that job well a
lot of those jobs aren't there anymore
no yeah no i mean the pandemic has
taught employers that
the between the pandemic and big data i
mean if you're if you're a big law firm
i mean you're not going to graduate from
undergrad and go become paralegal
paralegal might be in mumbai with the
entire
law library on a chip
so i i think it's very difficult for for
new kids and i actually have my son's
graduating college here in the summer
and of course he's like most young kids
and he wants to be a chief marketing
officer of a gaming company
scares me of death i try to talk about
financing not interested
but uh you know he really wants to be in
branding
and branding for video games but i told
him i'm like listen you you can be do
branding at anything right and the funny
that you brought up your story about
dallas there because i said the best
place to do branding is in high-end by
the way yeah because they actually have
sales yeah
um
but yeah it's a huge problem on how you
keep young kids motivated jobs created
for them and keep this economy going
yeah it's it's astounding that that
that
you rather report about dennis mcgill
from summoning associates i mean
if his math is right we're going to go
from 25 percent of kids of adults living
with their parents in 2020 to 29
in 2030. i think he's right going the
wrong way
i think he's right just because the
opportunity is right the opportunities
are gonna be tough or you're gonna have
you know six kids living in an apartment
right well i mean it's it's difficult to
convey to this younger
generation that
that
that undergraduate degrees are
commodities
they've been commoditized they're kind
of meaningless i mean you can't stop at
your bba you have to get something else
when it comes to education to
differentiate yourself in the
marketplace that's just effectively
shrinking
and we see that in the labor force
petition participation rate at to your
point every single time there's a boom
and a bust we have structural damage
inflicted to the participation rate it's
just it's it's terrible
yeah i don't know what the answer for
that one is you're gonna have to figure
out how to create more jobs and one of
the things i liked about i read this
story about germany
and their educational system that i
found fascinating that's something we
don't do in this country
which is they would look at
the quality of the student and kind of
what they were best suited for right and
they would really steer a whole bunch of
kids toward trades right whether you're
suited to be an electrician or whatever
and anybody who walks in your house i
mean i mean summer's here in texas i
mean man you're hvac guys he's killing
it he's killing it
so i you know i think that's a thing
that this country doesn't do well
there's a lot of opportunity in the
trades
and we tend to tell everybody in this
country that you need to go to school
because you need to be a finance guy or
a doctor or a lawyer
something really important of course and
we don't look up upon the trades people
the way we should without them no no we
don't survive but they sure do have nice
incomes they do and i think that's
that's probably something this country
should really focus on no i um
and germany uh
retrains
current workers there's like a public
private partnership between the
government of germany and
you know and employers to where if you
know that the technology is going to
change you're going to reskill your
worker while your workers working
absolutely and i'm like well there's a
nice thought yeah whereas we say go and
unemployment good luck
exactly you're done you're made
redundant there goes your industry there
goes what you what you're doing for a
living it's you've been
you've been innovated away
so um
so
i'll ask a a a question about china by
asking a question about germany okay
if if germany had to choose
say in two or three years if germany had
to choose between china and the united
states which country would germany
choose
as far as a trading partner is that what
you mean in the event that you go
from
currency where to trade war to hot war
hypothetically
because we've all got this on our radar
right now i mean
we talk about taiwan we talk about a
very tangentially we talk about ukraine
very trained because no geopolitical
event has affected the markets
since we've been in the business
yeah i think
frankly if i'm germany
it's probably not the united states
and i hate to say that because you know
i love this country etc but
there's 1.3 billion people in china if
you're going to sell cars and that's
what germany does best
i'm probably going to pick that market
well they they do more business with
china than they do with the united
states it's period and it's it's a very
recent
it's a very recent flip
um but
in direct investing i mean
it's it's the same thing like you know
would you rather be a partner with india
than than here
probably
it's probably going to outpace you know
this population outpace china at the
pace they're going look i mean i think
internationally they don't have any
roads but
i think international infrastructure in
india is probably going to be a safe
place to be in the next year it's going
to be a good place to die if you can get
to the politicians and actually you know
get the ground i mean government
corruption has obviously been the
biggest impediment to making india the
next china yeah um and i think somebody
will figure it out the impact china's
had i think globally is just astounding
um like we have some investments and i
won't name the private equity guy that
does
he's paying asian
uh this private equity buyout shop that
we have money with
and it's interesting because the returns
are staggering staggeringly good i mean
just amazing
and you know i was talking my private
equity guy in my shop i'm like how much
of that is china because that's where
he's killing
so we pulled up went through line item
by line item not one
not one investment is in china wow right
so
this is i'm not gonna say who it is but
it's a massive global player
it's like one of the biggest powerhouse
firms in the world yeah
you gotta ask yourself why
well china is at a 30-year i mean
china's growth rates at a 30-year low
from what we're being told that's
probably not true i i don't first of all
i have a hard time believing that um i'm
sure we're being told that but even with
that said
there is massive investment opportunity
available in china like let's just talk
about health care first i mean that is
that is a huge area where you can make a
killing
you can make a killing in technology in
china right the scale we had one manager
built burger kings of all things
you built 275 burger kings it was a 5x
trade for us gosh on burger king it's
not even that good right no
i went down the street in dallas it just
closed right
so it might my point is why would this
manager who
is clearly a global
global manager that's phenomenal not
touch china
yeah
is it because the other opportunities
are so great
or is it because we're concerned about
china
i think it's the latter
i think there's plenty of opportunities
they have people on the ground in china
in china i think they're seeing the same
thing that a lot of people are seeing
which is
what's going to happen in china and how
are they really going to treat american
how is the conflict going on i got to
get my money out and and we're talking
about locking stuff up that could be 10
year lock
right
this isn't a
public equity trade it's you're buying a
private company and then trying to build
it
and this firm who i consider to be one
of the best has said no
we're not going to do that
and to me that's like a canary in the
coal mine that says wow maybe we should
be paring back
for instance at tech you know five years
ago we started doing
private credit in china
uh we also have some venture cap there
we have we have a number of things there
but we we've been talking about this
this last year it's like okay now we
have a track record of this private
credit in china how much better is it
than develop market private credit
like are we getting paid
to take that to take that risk and i'm
not just saying currency risk i'm
talking geopolitical risks no you're
talking about nationalization you're
talking about nationalism absolutely
there's a lot of risk here that we can't
underwrite wow like maybe for the cia we
could but cia done calls and help us
with that exactly so you know we sat
there and looked at it and i you can go
back and look at there's four different
managers in private crowd that we have
over there
only one of them's really done better
than
our other managers that are you know
whether they're in europe or the united
states the other three are just kind of
in the middle of the road
so what are we doing
we're cutting ties with all of them
yeah all four and we're like look we're
taking an awful lot of risk
that we can't quantify well
and we're not really getting much for it
let's just come back and have a place
where we know the rule of laws on our
side right
um i mean the irony of china is that
their their doors are wide open for
money to come in
right and yet the saber rattling is
getting really loud right it's almost
like having children money always goes
out it never comes back gosh that's so
true
especially the one daughter
but i mean i think that's a big issue
for everybody to think about in
in the institutional side is you know
how tight do you want to get to china
and how much money you're willing to put
over there there's a lot of arguments to
put more money right msci
you know they're very low weight in the
index but they're slowly growing
a lot of people are going hey we should
be gdp weighting this they should be way
higher
oh so think about that if you gdp wait
that thing gosh you're quadrupling your
allocation
so i mean these dilemmas are being
argued in public pension funds all over
the country and endowments um we're
choosing not to gdp weight i think
that's
not the right way to think about it
myself
i would say if they were a true you know
more of a democracy an open society i
probably would be right sure but we're
learning quickly but they're not
and i think the
opportunity for us to have conflict with
them is growing rapidly
i think it's almost inevitable
so you think that something will happen
with taiwan
i think it i think it's highly probable
some could have with taiwan well we
didn't do anything about hong kong so
we also didn't do anything about crimea
and we haven't talked about russia well
that's a whole nother problem with
russia on the border right now in a gas
line that everybody's willing to look
the other way because they need gas in
europe right well yeah i mean vladimir
putin's got a lot of power these days
and i've heard that freight is a train
wreck in
in russia as well that they've got their
own supply chain difficulties that
they're dealing with on top of vladimir
putin being a dictator effectively
uh
but russia and china share the largest
contiguous
land
border in the world
i mean they're right on top of each
other
i just think they would make interesting
allies i
i think you very well could see that
starting to happen i mean you can almost
see kind of a new world order between if
they ever got together and actually
could
tolerate each other enough to work
together that's the real question
because
putin's his own guy and jg thing is he's
you know they're they're real people
um but if they ever tie together well
you're talking about
awfully strong block
that what nato is going to come
take them on i mean as far as i know all
the power of nato russ kind of
singular with the united states almost
um i don't think germany has airplanes
anymore
if they do they're involved well germany
has been building up its army germany's
been building up its military in recent
years and this is kind of a very quiet
development because when you think about
russia and china
and borders
you need to build it up and i think that
was when when trump was in office and i
know he was not popular
but one of the things in my opinion that
he did was you know kind of
saber rattle at nato and say hey we're
paying for everything doing everything
that's great since world war ii that
we're able to do that it's now your time
to start picking up
and spending what you agreed to spend at
a minimum yep
um i think that was very smart and i
think we should continue that policy of
pushing well i mean again
you're right he was not popular but
there were generations of
u.s presidents who ignored
what china was stealing from the united
states i mean at least he you know went
off and sent off a tweet
and got the country more aware right of
the threat that china posed and as soon
as the country became aware of the
threat that china posed
all of a sudden you start to see xi
jinping
exert his power and take down jack ma
and go after the billionaires and
you know allow evergrand to blow up and
and it's this it's
march
the pace of his march is quickened yeah
and
and then you talk about russia and all
those natural resources
i mean russia's got more natural
resources than anybody on the planet
it's actually a phenomenal partnership
if they ever do pull together right i
mean it's right because that's the one
thing that china doesn't have is energy
and they both have they all also both
have a little bit of a disdain for the
rest of the developed world so if you
put those two together that's that's
kind of frightening
it also has a huge implication on
business too right like if you think
just about markets and companies so
almost every company in the united
states outsource
to china i mean there's tons of
manufacturing china that's all for us
companies
being produced there in fact i know a
local guy he sells t-shirts cups pens
that kind of marking the tails business
buys that's his thing
and he was having a horrible time during
covet why because every single thing
that he sells it's made in china yeah so
it was during coba like everything got
locked down he didn't sell anything i
mean we were we were here a few nights
ago and and
christopher cole said look around this
office probably fifty percent of
everything in this office was made in
china
if you if you think about it and
i mean if you think about the whole idea
of nationalization and if you look at
the microcosm example of what happened
in venezuela
i mean if you're a big us company you've
got tremendous exposure risk and yet
it's so expensive to
move your supply chain
but they're going to have to
i think i think
i think mexico will benefit i'm pointing
i think i'm pointing to mexico i think
mexico is going to benefit from this i
agree i mean vietnam benefits i think
mexico vanderbilt i mean these are
countries with better demographics too
right
the other thing that i would think is a
policy thing because i mean we touch on
the fact that we're concerned about
what's the opportunity for younger kids
right in this new new world that we're
living in now and i think globalization
has taken away a lot of opportunity for
developed worlds yeah is there
advantages absolutely we can buy more
stuff
right
but that's what it's about it's about
the rich having more stuff
right at a cheaper price
nicer things right
in silicon valley you know these massive
companies and there's no anti-trust to
speak of in the united states america i
think that's patently apparent but you
know silicon valley the largest
employers in the united states
employ fewer people based on the money
they make so they're not these massive
employers they're not at all and yet
they're the biggest companies in america
yeah
absolutely agree
but i'm thinking that if you could
get the supply chain problem so if that
supply chain problem comes back here
like we're doing it with chips right now
the government's helping sponsors sure
strategic
but if you just think of all the other
things that are manufactured
we should be able to pull back some of
that stuff into the united states right
the united states has to be at a point
where they're comfortable enough paying
more money for items
right so it's going to drive inflation
right
but if you want to put young people to
work
the rich got to be willing to pay more
for stuff
right
or you got to put some tariffs on stuff
coming in to try to equalize the cost
right supply chain coming back 24
percent of your average united states
cars parts come from china come from
china 24 is not a that's a strategic
problem risk anyway yeah right
um i'm not saying i have the answer to
it but we've outsourced so much stuff
through globalization
that we need to bring some of it back so
that we create our own economy and
strengthen our own economy a little bit
well and maybe this is the last thing
you can you can speak to how is covet
impacted
this dynamic how's the pandemic affected
it
uh as far as bringing assets back home
you mean
i'm sure it slowed it right um
well we're importing out our eyeballs i
think that's finally slowing down yeah i
i hope it starts slowing down and more
people go back to work here
i think covet's impacted
broadly just like real estate markets
and everything in a crazy fashion it's
like you go to new york right
but new york's still a ghost town like i
talked to my managers there and most of
them aren't even working in the office
and new york accounts for a gigantic
proportion of office buildings in this
country and they've still got cranes up
so it's i mean it's it's it's kind of
frightening right because the people's
demand for foreplay is going to rapidly
change it's going to impact real estate
prices
i think you're much safer in
residential even though we talked about
the residential might be getting an
overshot too look i mean
the the pool of individuals who could be
converted on paper with a mortgage from
a renter to a home buyer
that pool that spiked during covet has
come completely back down to
pre-pandemic levels
and we've got a demographic issue on our
hand that few people are aware of yeah i
absolutely agree and and commercial real
estate is also multi-family
like it has not been in any other cycle
i mean
tell me
share the story about the building that
was sold and what the cap rate was yes
this is obviously one of my favorite
stories because i in
25 years i've never sold a building at
this kind of gap right
so so capture it is explain what a cap
rate is if you don't mind it it's like a
price to earning ratio for for a stock
only it's for for profit but the lower
it is the lower it is lower it is more
expensive
it's inverse right so the lower it is
the better
so
this was
right down here in downtown austin on
red river
um so just a block off congress
and we bought this
several years ago because
the university of texas was building out
a medical center and frankly this was
within walking distance to it and they
hadn't really started building it at the
time we bought it but we knew it was
coming yeah and we're like if you just
get in front of that demand is going to
be really high yeah
you know it's going to be it's a rental
we'll do we'll do okay right we'll do
we'll do all right so we bought it
and uh then co would hit and actually we
had a bunch of vacancies because kids
moved back home right of course so this
property kind of went like this right
came back up
and then recently we sold it at a 2.4
cap rate gosh 2.4 oh my gosh which means
we printed money
and that's just insane and it is you
can't even see 2.4 and like i don't even
understand the other side's argument
like why you're buying a fully leased
building at that at that price
because there's no upside left unless
you think inflation's just going to go
crazy unless you think rents are going
to accelerate off of a 10 base and by
the way rents have are continuing to
increase so you know maybe they are
smarter but
um i don't think long run that's a good
trade for it well just just put 2.4 in
perspective if you would like what would
it have been in
in 2007
at the peak at the last peak of the
commercial real estate market oh i would
say it's probably more like a four cap
right yes right and that's just like if
you assault that peak it was probably
more like a four so i mean you're
talking magnitudes better
and we've got cranes up all over the
country yeah god bless you i think this
is a i think this is an accident waiting
to happen by the way this is what makes
a market
like from my perspective i think that's
the best trade in the world because i
sold to somebody else at that rate that
other side he thinks he's got a great
deal because he has some view
that austin's going to continue to grow
forever that inflation's going to
continue to go that rents are going to
continue to go up that's his feel
right it's a zero-sum game yeah playing
in the market
well you have to have every trade has to
have two sides right yeah regardless of
your assets i've been at 25 years i
think i'm going to win this one but oh i
think i think it's a it's a home run i'm
thinking it's a home run so uh
so one last question so
is there anything existential about
uh
working for texas tech
and yet
you're you know you're here in in the
land of the burnt orange so
i mean do you ever feel conflicted
during college football season never
never
never feel convict conflicted at all i
mean
i love university of texas i think
they've spent 58 million dollars
changing coaches over the weekend i
don't want to talk about it and they
have the worst track record that they've
had for 25 years
so god bless you like health care in
america the more we spend the worse it
gets no i am uh i'm a red raider through
and through guns up i didn't go there
but i've adopted them and uh god love
you good i love it when they play ut now
this year was not fun for me because you
beat them yep but uh i've been to
several games when texas tech won and
you know couldn't be more happy in fact
i surround myself with my ut friends
when i go to them
i love that
tim um
this austin series is gonna become a
regular thing so i'd love to
a year from now or so let's let's check
back with each other
and see see how the world has changed
and see how that how those evaluations
have
have i because i think and i think a
year from now we'll know some things i
think they're absolutely going to change
thanks for all your time i appreciate it
i appreciate it thank you well i hope
you enjoyed visiting with tim barrett
that was fabulous we covered a lot of
ground i hope you've enjoyed this austin
series we'll come back
uh if if you missed for any reason the
interview that i did with dr keith brown
who was my inspiration told me to go to
wall street
uh and sits on the boards of the ut
endowment sits on the board of the
largest teachers pension in in texas
combine their insights go back and watch
his and then and then go back and watch
tim's over again because i'm going to
have to watch it twice i learned so much
and you'll have a better appreciation
for public pensions and for universities
and for entities that really won't go
away in our lifetimes right universities
don't go away so the money has to be
managed so it's it's critical that as as
as learners that we we understand how
they operate uh and if for some reason
you have not gone to quail
intelligence.com please please visit the
website uh my research gives you just as
much of an education as these series do
and for now i will bid you farewell and
i appreciate you visiting with down the
middle this is danielle demartino booth
thank you
[Music]